did you guys see the video of Kevin
Gates spitting in the girl's mouth on
stage he's vient that's the grossest
[__] I've seen have a wife no he just be
up you know his him and his wife have a
complicated relationship that I won't
speak on because I don't know the
details but they are very uh open I
don't know but I just know that he does
his thing you seen a shorty shorty [__]
when you punched the f
yes I did why he punched the P cuz he
was banging on him in the front row
pause I don't know I thought it was his
op or some [__] like well the dude was
like throwing up a bunch of sets shorty
shorty mad [__] NY shorty Rock
thisit rocked him in the crowd you guys
shouldn't do that some [__] lick the
CRA I don't know what happened like you
never know what happened ganger what
happened um someone licked you why you
keep telling me Yoo what's why you keep
telling people somebody lick me that was
a one time thing real about that I was
at a show I'm in feel me I'm just
regularly going to see the fans and [__]
going in the crowd I'm walking dapping
[__] up and [__] I don't know it
somebody on the back of my ear oh what
the [__] was on your shoulder you lying
[__] it was right here bro wait so a
dude was it a dude bro I don't know
whato you feel me I turned around and
everybody cut everybody cut y got
serious some dedicated fans yo can you
imagine how weird of a human being you
gota be to just go lick a yo that's wild
and wasn't we had a show it was a show
like you was sweating
like what about this is my chance I'm
Lick Lick is crazy I don't know if I
ever see these guys again no no no
that's a little too crazy [__] probably
never washed his tongue he probably yeah
[__] probably say anybody any tattoos
of you guys huh four1 tattoo yeah we got
four tto know what I'm saying any fans
yeah nice my son je just found a f
titties did she get a tattooos uh no did
you do anything else with the titties
after n hell no she had
some titties was
nasty
just oh my God yo titties is just
like perfect titties is just the best
like I hate a [__] with no titties bro
bad titties what about that bad
titties cuz like the titties can make up
for like if a [__] don't got a fat a
the titties make up bro now you need
titties you just talk about this [__]
just talk about this [__] about
that you guys ass or titty guys titties
titties titties it w't really be about
the ass bro really be about the [__]
[__] what about that my my keep
tripping it's cord what about now it's
better you can hear me yeah it's just
this cord's tripping [__] cord um all
right so we have no idea when your ep's
coming out even though you do I do
November soon n yo chill bro soon
probably tomorrow probably yesterday
probably next
week I might have a text that says when
it comes out to let me
see let's
see do I have a text no what's going on
you can
hit just did bad okay I don't have a
text before
Halloween maybe definitely when's
Halloween again so in October we're
going to get an
[Music]
EP before December 1st we're going to
get a
e yes
yes
you so in November we're getting an
EP we can say that we could say that
yeah sometime in November we don't know
what it's called and we don't know who's
on it or maybe sometime in October or
maybe yeah is the mop song I like on
there the Annie Up remix definitely
great that's good to
hear uh that's it that's it that's the
only song so no it's not the only how
many songs like six seven eight nine
something like that I think probably
eight n eight n eight or nine yeah all
right well POS BL plus a bonus probably
plus a bonus I like that all right guys
well uh I look forward to the EP
appreciate you guys hanging out again
we number one was it number one most
added it's still number one still it
just went number we just went this is
still number one again just went back so
if I go and check right now it's going
to be number one apple music in New
York this [__] my court is tripping
balls tripping balls is this isn't this
a mugami c
warm like you got to buy aami tape it's
number two what beat y'all
out I didn't see I'm be honest just Dro
bro they
just just pushed us yo Drake violated
Drake violated you guys are five you
guys made stop no cuz pull up the
screenshot like a day L guys yo D just
came out of nowhere
bro
the last you I want to congrats on the
top 25 in New York City you guys are
number five we definitely been above top
five hey top five is not bad number one
number one we was just number one
yesterday I got the
screenshot hey that's first of all
that's amazing I didn't I don't have
apple music so I wouldn't even know to
see I don't have apple music either I
like Spotify you don't got Apple music
so what you listen to music on oh I see
SoundCloud we talking YouTube premiums I
see the screenshot B that [__] is St
congratulations apprciate you that's a
big deal
man it's been about two weeks BR tenders
they like $30 a month well you know what
I like about y'all you guys are bringing
like great energy out of New York not
too much negativity y'all just on moving
on some positive vibes you know trying
to spread positivity man putting out
good music Good Records yeah and then
obviously getting licked uh by random
people and then you you your [__]
Tinder pictures are about to go viral
Bud yeah your Tinder gold your [__]
lit have you gone on in La yet inter
right now I'm going call you back
later huh have you gone like open Tinder
in La yet oh yeah is it going
up
yeah the tinder's lit tinder's lit bro
did you watch the Tinder swindler on
Netflix
no it's about this guy who would like
take advantage of women off a Tinder how
would he I mean he made like millions of
dollars he was like a con artist wait
like how would he get them to like you
watch it on Netflix like he he was
having him s him bread so he like he
like no he presented himself to be like
this Rich millionaire dude right so then
he would like date these women and like
convince them that like something would
happen with his bank account or
something I could you just let me like
hold on to 50,000 I send it back to you
tomorrow or whatever the 50,000 yeah and
then only a dumb [__] will send a [__]
50,000 over
Tinder well there's some dumb [__]
out there is dumb [__] some dumb ass
def there's some dumb [__] out there
I hate dumb [__] me too those the worst
type of [__] my dad worst type of
[__] are the pretty dumb [__] like
yo like it's so pretty to be so stupid
like you was so pretty to be such a th
like yo a man I don't even want to start
cuz I start whing these [__] up on
this interview there's definitely some
pretty dumb [__] out there mhm dumb
ass house I don't know why it's usually
and I hate a ugly dumb [__] too yeah oh
or ugly dumb fat
[__] yo cuz yeah shout out to the ugly
BBWs you know you got you can't be ugly
and dumb G pick one pick a struggle like
what are you doing if you're going to be
ugly at least be smart yeah you know F
or suck dick well that's what the the
fat chicks usually do that
best I I know I can't speak on that what
do you mean bro I never [__] no I feel
like you're the guy in the crew that'll
jump on the
grenade jump on a grenade B Ain no more
like let's say there's a a bunch of like
there's a crew [__] right mhm and you
think I'm taking the worst [__] G I get
the best [__] every you tri I think
you're jumping on the grenade for the
crew it don't even be a grenade like
sometimes it be a grenade brings a group
of girls and his chick's fire but her
friends are whatever you're [__] the
ugly ones why me cuz you're a good
friend are you a good friend it got to
be not ugly though you got to understand
not ugly ugly like decent [__] like
not just bad I'm not taking nothing for
the team no we not doing that [__] yeah
these [__] coming for me [__] is you
talking about why would I take one for
the
team is it you no you're not the grenade
jumper no we don't got a Grenade jumper
yeah gang I ain't going to lie if you
have a grenade a couple grenade jumpers
we don't allow grenades no no grenades
coming to the premises bro we don't Jack
The Fat Friends gangster